part of what you're highlighting here is
there's a mindset right now I heard you
on a recent interview you basically said
look this whole crisis is in your head
right and I thought that was a really
illuminating statement and really
because what it does is it is the way
you react to the crisis right the crisis
is gonna happen whether you like it or
not we all don't want it to happen but
it's happening and the crisis being in
your head essentially the way I heard it
was you can either let it happen to you
and you be the receiver of all of that
pain or you can be responsible and have
personal responsibility and basically
say look I got a navigate this correctly
and if you're really good now will you
navigate it successfully but you
actually come out the other side
stronger wealthier better positioned
then you went into it but it all comes
from that mindset of am I gonna let the
world happen to me or am I gonna kind of
implement my will on the world that's
the curse right right I mean if you're
not doing well if you're not thriving
today in this crisis then someone to
your head
somebody crawled upside your butt and
into your head and messed with it you
know God is cool get a job a car taxes
save money and get out of debt and then
invest a little long term in a
well-diversified portfolio stocks bonds
mutual funds and ETFs if you've done
that you're in big trouble so as you
know if you don't change your thoughts
you don't change your life and that's
why I've been you know I've been
tweeting on I know I'm so old I don't
know what Twitter is what was the talk
oh I said Oh YouTube man there's some
the best teachers all right - and
they're not getting paid
stupid academic rates you know they
don't have ten there most of them if
they're a real teacher they're doing
really well today you're doing well I'm
doing well I would listen to us not that
phony and Harvard you know the peacetime
leader yeah but I think that this also
like what you're highlighting you know
and again you've said it before is like
the dying of the Industrial Age and and
really the acceleration of a shift to
information age maybe explain that
a little bit what do you mean when you
say the Industrial Age is ending and
we're now really getting thrust into
that Information Age well look at what
we're doing today you know I mean you
know Industrial Age when when it would
change from agrarian to industrial the
horse saw the car doing I mean the horse
could see the car and that's a tow my
job was done and the horse was finished
that's up for racing but today you can't
see the change so one way so in 1989
when the world wide web came up and the
Berlin Wall came down simultaneously I
thought that was interesting you know so
that was it's another transformation
it's no different than when you know
let's say I'm a king I'm a king and
Portugal or something and I got all my
archers and my swords guys in my spirit
guys and some entrepreneur drives up
there with his cannon he doesn't loads
that cannon blows the guy's walls down
you know but that's kind of what's
happening today you know all the old
guys standing in their castle walls and
some entrepreneurs senator pound the
crap out of them
so exactly when I was with Steve Burke
of NBC Universal he was saying the guys
like what we're doing the guys on social
media are kicking their butts right now
they don't know what to do you know they
can't stop us so that's kind of what I'm
talking about the problem is the average
person because they went to school
looking for a job they can't see what's
going on they're blind so you know like
and I think was on York young program
you hold up a cell phone you got more
power in that cell phone then when I
first went to the Academy in New York in
65 they had full you know rooms blown
Sperry computers and all that you got
more power in that cell phone than that
Sperry computer at my school in New York